[Musique]
pourquoi tes moutons les vinyles tu as
un objectif entre les mains j'adore ça
voilà
tu es en train d'enregistrer la première
chanson de notre compilation
[Musique]
tu vas croire que je suis folle
je viens du futur
quoi du futur avec les hoverboards et
tout c'est pas une blague tu vas mourir
je sais pas comment te le dire sans
passer pour une folle mais je voyage
dans le temps comment tout ça est
possible j'en sais rien mais chaque fois
que j'écoute une chanson de notre
cassette ça me ramène au moment où on
l'a entendu ensemble
Laura
comment je peux être ici quoi est-ce que
tu parles pourquoi tu parles tu es
vivant
certains prétendent que la musique
transcende l'espace et le temps mais
j'ai toujours cru que c'était une
métaphore je sais pas combien de temps
il nous
on a une chance de sauver il faut qu'on
soit prudent j'ai qu'à changer ce qui se
passe le jour de ma mort l'univers a eu
plein rien ne pourra jamais le changer
pas sensé le sauver la plupart des gens
n'ont droit qu'à un essai avec la
personne qui s'aime toi de ton aide 2
c'est vraiment que c'est le seul moyen
rien d'autre n'a fonctionné aussi
longtemps que tu seras en vie je suis
heureuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]